usa câmera feijão da otan em o colar
tudo isso ando aqui quem fala é o dar
que sejam muito bem vindos
são mais de um niver e nós não estamos
aqui para julgar bug é deixar o gato
porque vocês têm dado desta série está
se mesmo do paúl tipo morro do castro
dentro do quarto e vamos fazer isso
consegui passar esta noite eu duvido
muito mas vamos tentar até meia noite
três misto quase a acabar o jogo
a roupa não quer saber esta miúda não
percebe que não quer seguir o que ela
diz a bíblia importa vamos prestar
atenção às coisas básicas que janela
porta vem lução e armário é só isso pois
o ouvi um barulho muito forte e sai
bicho foi meu serviço foi alto e tem que
abaixar o som steel abril 20 loção oil
free
desta vez bruno pescoço enquanto comer
pô restart não não funciona
não posso olhar para a macaca agora né
neve emoção já está aberta outra porque
eu a porta lixo do monocoque como é que
é possível e é isto que está aqui o fred
não passou nenhum não é porque me faz
este barulho pra parceiro no lado oposto
e não como mero cuba já não vou deixar
eu falando agora
ai meu deus ai ai manter no poder embora
pouco tempo a sair daqui acho que é mais
rápido e man on olho na janela ou outro
foco ela parece um lado pro outro rápido
aí a razão do barulho além do bahia
importa é o que eu gosto dele no coração
é o sangue
ai ai telefonema meu deus meu deus ai
meu deus não recorra a haia ainda
cantava ai eu tô na instituição em medo
estava mito não não sei ou seja você sai
aimar eo nenê vocês estão tipo de medo
não eu mesma fiquei à frente também não
seja isso é outra não conheço nem tudo
uma boa olimpíada em pilhas aa isso em
cima dos olhos não tenho culpa pois como
resposta que amanhã o foco foi dar outra
vez
meu deus eu não sei como é que eu vou
aguentar até ao fac sua dinâmica toda
verde ai ai ai meu deus senão tudo são
para ser para todos os ramos incluindo
aí a normal e sai bicho nova campanha
pela rápida a espanha não apenas a uma
pena final só fica fora se ele estava
com essas áreas têm muita incerteza eu
já ficava na cinta manhã o km 84 através
do pai jovem um barulho aqui falou
ai ai eu abri uma ventilação ó mas foi
quem mandou matar na porta na boca não
quer saber e não há ninguém a sé é amigo
ou amiga ou amigo eu sou nature janela e
não vi ter deixado ele ter acendido a
luz né
saiba que ficou aiaiai anel sai daqui do
molhe da kantar tocou o chão estava
chegando na porta é do yuan
ok eu já não precisa muito tempo eu não
pareça muito mimo
o boca-a-boca janela tvs não é um amigo
não vai conseguir um trecho da manhã foi
para 50 nos ao máximo centavos de euro
precisa de melhoras bota faz 13 de maio
e da manhã com mais dois minutinhos o
sapo ajuda é com esta luz é bem sabido
ofícios a não ser pedir para que
washington saiba quem morre ao cair no
mar está tranqüilo porto também janela
também ventilação também tá tudo bem
aqui ao não conseguir nada comigo porque
não fazendo aqui sai daqui da moita em
duas pneus pilhas pneus pilhas pilhas
são pilhas marques 15 da manhã o maior
dentro com a segunda feira 15 foi de
manhã que só mais um minuto na hora que
vai apanhar a curvinha bayern vai ai que
mexeu no lixo e retirou nenhuma outra
vez pão e sempre nestas alturas que vai
começar no organismo que o chão seguir
50 conseguir o que eu consegui disse me
que eu conseguir
então é isso pessoal não chega porque os
filhos para que vocês tenham gostado
muito obrigado pelo vosso povo e pelo
povo francês tem nada nesta série está
sendo mesmo o sangue é isso que mostra
que curitiba pr pela quinta noite e até
a próxima